Speaker 1: All right. I don't want to spend a lot
of time on this, but I do want to give you a quick
update. There is a new Trump reinstatement day.
Now, I know, you know, most of you understand
what's going on here, which is there is no
such thing as Trump's reinstatement. And
eventually it's just going to be. Well, the way to
reinstate Trump is to vote for him again in 2024
if he runs again in 2024. But absent the
August 13th reinstatement, we're now only
six days from the end of August. Clearly, Donald
Trump is not going to be reinstated in August
or at all, but certainly not in August. My pillow
CEO, Mike Lyndell or Mike Pillow for shorthand,
former guest on this program is now saying, well,
it's going to be by New Year's. That's the new
one. Our friend Zachary Patrizio writing for Salon
Pillow magnate turned election conspiracy theorist
Mike Lyndell has a new prediction. Donald Trump
will be back in the Oval Office by New Year's Eve.
For months, Lyndell floated August as the deadline
for Trump's reinstatement landing on August 13th
as the day Biden's electoral
victory would be thrown out.
Though the 13th passed without any developments
and his South Dakota Cyber Symposium fell flat,
the infamous My Pillow CEO is still in Trump's
good graces, earning a glowing endorsement from
the previous commander in chief at a packed rally
in Cullman, Alabama, Saturday night. Trump said
Michael Dell is a patriot, a wonderful I think he
actually said patriot, a wonderful man, a man who
puts his guts into everything, a man they don't
treat properly. He's smart. He loves his country
so much he's willing to die for this country.
The new one from Mike Pillow is this year,
this year, meaning December 31st, presumably
of twenty twenty one. Let's take a listen
Speaker 5: to the twenty twenty two, twenty
twenty one change. Now we can't wait the
twenty twenty four for things to reverse.
This country is going down a road right now,
Speaker 1: by the way, this interviewer.
I'm pretty sure it's a sycophant because
it's Rightside broadcasting, but if
this were a trolling interviewer,
he would be saying the exact same thing. We can't
wait till 20, 24, can we? Can it happen sooner
Speaker 5: to be reversed now? Has
to happen now. It's twenty twenty
one hundred twenty one and it's out this election
when it does get pulled down. You know, there
are so many other there that maybe the Supreme
Court just relax, which is fine. But remember,
everybody, we have to melt down the machines to
make prisoners out of them. That's a fact. I wish.
Speaker 1: Aren't the machines
plastic anyway? Why how do
you make a prison bar out of it to
Speaker 5: the Alabama secretary of state,
Mr. President?
Speaker 1:
OK, so there is Mike Lyndell. This is this is very
much like the rapture people. And it's interesting
that Mike Lyndell is a self professed religious
guy and he talks a lot about how God is part of
what got him out of drug addiction and so on and
so forth. To the extent that that's true, that's
great. That that he says he's no longer having
a problem with with drug addiction, drug abuse
of drugs. But this is very, very much like the
rapture type stuff. And we've covered this before.
There's the sliding prophecy dates. It's a really
important part of doomsday cults where you have
to keep people going. If you never set a date,
people may not follow you because they're like,
God, whatever, OK, someday, but when when is the
date? So that kind of pushes them to set a date.
But then the date comes to pass and of course,
nothing happens. And so they have to set a new
date and you've got to keep people hooked. And
it's a very common tactic of these doomsday cults.
There was this so long ago that I'm having a hard
time remembering. It might have been 2012 where
the Harold Camping, this was an organization. Let
me see if I can actually find it. Harold Camping
prophecy. It was 2011, actually, where
Harold Camping, a Christian radio host, said
May 21, 2011 is going to be the date. And we
interviewed a woman. I think it was like April,
March or April. And you can find the interview
on my YouTube channel is incredible to see.
And she is just sure that it's going to happen.
And when I said, what if it doesn't? She said,
you know, if it doesn't, it means I wasn't
chosen for heaven or something like that.
It didn't happen. Then they pushed
the date to October 21st. Apparently,
Harold Camping had misread the tea leaves in
some way or something like that. Obviously, it
didn't happen. We basically never heard from them
again. And we tried to get a follow up interview
with the woman who was just sure she was getting
raptured on May 21st. We never heard back from her
either. That's this is basically a doomsday cult
with Trump's imaginary reinstatement, which is
just as unlikely, as unlikely as you think that I
don't know, tomorrow Jesus will return and people
will be raptured and some die and some go to
heaven. As unlikely as you believe that is Trump
being reinstated this year is just as unlikely.
Now, you could say, well, David, one of these
things is sort of like metaphysically impossible,
right? Like there's not going to be this rapture
in theory. Trump could be president, OK? It's
almost as unlikely. It is almost as it's not a
physical impossibility, but it is essentially
as unlikely that Trump will be reinstated.
And the the the shifting goalposts is a big part
of it. And Mike Lyndell is doing exactly that